-Today's Friday.
That's usually when I catch up
with some personal stuff.
You know, I check my inbox,
return some e-mails,
and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
James, can I get some thank-you
note writing music, please?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Thank you, December.
Between the World Cup
and The Rockettes,
big month for kicking.
Big month for kicking!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, making snow angels,
for letting me finally do
jumping jacks the way I want --
slowly and lying down.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hunh!
♪♪
-Thank you, gingerbread men,
for always dressing like
you're going to an interview
at Chippendales.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, the holidays,
for being the only time
the Billboard Hot 100
features Drake, Nicki Minaj,
and Bing Crosby.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hunh!
Wah-chh!
♪♪
-Thank you,
"It's a Wonderful Life,"
for being the heartwarming story
of a man
who yells at his children
before wishing he was dead.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
♪♪
-Thank you, myrrh,
for sounding like
the third Wise Man
forgot a present and just
mumbled something to cover.
Like, "I got you, uh, myrrh."
[ Applause ]
"I got you what --
What do you mean, what is it?
It's myrrh.
It's myrrh."
[ Laughter ]
-Ch!
♪♪
-Thank you,
New Year's resolutions,
for being
the most roundabout way
to tell everyone you're a mess.
There you have it, everybody!
Those are my thank-you notes.